la séance est reprise la parole est au
président de la commission des finances
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
Président donc je voudrais vous indiquer
d'abord que le nombre d'amendements
cette année déposés en première partie
du projet de loi de finances monte se
monte à
amendements par rapport à l'année année
dernière qui était déjà une espèce de de
record interne nous avons 500
amendements supplémentaires par rapport
à l'an
dernier alors il se trouve que nous
sommes tenus par des exigences
constitutionnelles prévu pour l'examen
du
budget et que donc ce nombre record nous
impose de revoir l' organisation de nos
travaux en effet il ne paraît pas
possible il est plus possible d'éviter
d'avoir séance la journée du dimanche 26
novembre et nous avons demandé en
conséquence l'ouverture l'après-midi le
soir et la
nuit aussi nous siègerons demain soir
jusqu'à minuit et
demi puis nous serions en séance samedi
à 9h30 14h30 le soir et la nuit jusqu'à
environ 2h num matin voire plus mais ça
ça dépend de vous nous reprendrions
dimanche à 14h et arrêterions vers 1h30
du matin dimanche enfin
lundi alors l'ouverture de 10h de séance
dimanche ça vous fait plaisir monsieur
le ministre de passer autant de temps
avec nous je vous remercie l'ouverture
de 10h de séance Dimanche nous empêchera
pas pour autant de devoir conserver un
rythme
soutenu pour discuter des amendements
séance pour achever l'examen de la
première partie jeudi prochain là on n'a
pas le choix hein c'est
ainsi voilà et je voulais vous citer une
phrase de mon prédécesseur Vincent rblé
lors du PLF 2019 qui avait eu une une
augmentation extrêmement significative
nombre d'amendements nous en étions à
1035 euh contre 617 l'année d'avant
c'est-àd en 2018 on en était à
617 en 2019 1035 et il avait dit
l'inflation est
substantielle alors ce coupci est au
double de ce chiffre là donc j'ai plus
de mots si vous voulez voilà donc on
essaiera de définir de trouver un
vocabulaire adapté voilà je je vous
indique j'ai demandé au chef de fil de
chacun des parties de d'avoir des
réflexions internes pour voir comment on
pouvait traiter les choses le plus le
mieux possible en respectant le droit de
chacun un des sénateurs mais en même
temps en faisant en sorte de ne pas trop
perdre de temps voilà et vous dire
également
donc que nous avons donc approuvé en
commission mais c'est tout à l'heure
qu'on nous le demandera l'amendement de
coordination sur l'article
liminire merci Monsieur pr donnera cet
avis je va demander l'avis du
Gouvernement merci Monsieur le le
Président je je confirme au président
renal tout tout le plaisir qui qui est
pour moi de de participer à ces travaux
et s'il faut rester dans le calendrier
que vous avez proposé dimanche compris
avec plaisir que je serai parmi
vous merci y y a-t-il des observations
sur les propositions qui viennent d'être
faites par le président de la commission
des finances s'il n'y en a pas il en est
ainsi décidé sur l'article liminaire
je suis saisi de deux amendements qui
font l'objet d'une discussion
commune monsieur le ministre s'agissant
du gouvernement merci Monsieur le le
président cet amendement met à jour les
prévisions sous-jacentes au projet de
loi de finances pour 2024 concernant à
la fois le le déficit et les grands
agrégats de finances publiques présentés
dans l'article liminire la mise à jour
résulte de la coordination avec les
différents textes financiers en
discussion au Parlement le plfs s 2024
et le plfg 2023 que vous avez adopté
hier donc que ce soit et c'est très
important pour nous pour 2023 ou pour
2024 les prévisions de sol public
restent inchangé respectivement à
4,9 - 4,9 % et
4,4 % conformément à la trajectoire
adoptée en loi de programmation des
finances publiqu pour 2023 l'amendement
prend en compte le résultat des
discussions du projet loi de finance de
fin de gestion définitivement adopté
hier par l'Assemblée et le Sénat et pour
2024 certains ajustements dégradent le
solde public comme l'impact nous en
avons parlé de l'accord national
interprofessionnel 2023-2026 pour laag
Carco moins 1 milliard d'euros sur le
sol de 2024 à l'inverse la mesure de gel
des barêes des allaigements généraux de
cotisation sociale introduite par
amendement dans le PLFSS lors de son
examen à l'Assemblée nationale permet
d'améliorer le solde de 500 millions
d'euros donc au total la prévision de
solde public pour 2024 s'établirait
toujours à - 4,4 % du PIB comme dans le
texte adopté par l'Assemblée nationale
et conformément aux orientations
dressées dans la loi de programmation
des finances
publiques merci Monsieur le Ministre
amendement suivant monsieur
Billac il est retiré il est retiré
je va demander l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur général sur
l'amendement du Gouvernement c'est un
avis favorable le président l'avait
d'ailleurs dit par anticipation mais
puisqu'on a rendu enfin j'ai rendu
l'avis en commission c'est c'est
vraiment un amendement de
coordination
merci je vais donc mettre au voie avec
cet amendement du Gouvernement avec un
avis favorable de la commission qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté je vais mettre maintenant au
voie
l'article liminire qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté nous
allons maintenant examiner l'article 33
relatif à l'évaluation du prélèvement
opéré sur les recettes de l'État au
titre de la participation de la France
au budget de l'Union
européenne dans le débat
euh on va peut-être attendre madame la
ministre propose
de là
voilà donc dans le débat la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Marie Mison rapporteur
spécial de la commission des finances
pour 5
minutes monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers
collègues comme chaque année il nous
revient d'examiner l'évaluation du
prélèvement sur 7 au profit de l'Union
européenne présentée dans le projet de
loi de finances il s'agit d'un exercice
complexe de la mesure où le moment le
montant inscrit dans le projet de loi de
finance est seulement
prévisionnel les négociations entre le
Conseil et le Parlement européen autour
du budget européen pour 2024 ont touché
ces derniers jours à leur fin le 11
novembre dernier ces deux institutions
se sont accordés sur un montant de 189
milliards d'euros en crédit d'engagement
et de 143 milliards d'euros en crédit de
paiement le 20 novembre le Conseil a
adopté ce compromis et le Parlement
européen a fait de même hier comme il
est d'usage le gouvernement devrait
déposer prochainement un amendement
prenant en compte le montant du budget
européen pour la contribution française
je regrette pour la clarté de nos débats
que nous ne disposions pas aujourd'hui
d'une évaluation révisée du